[Music]
there was a I was listening to a podcast
and uh they had an astrology expert on
and she was talking about what Megan Fox
it wasn't Megan Fox
um she was talking about like Saturn
reversal or something
you know what I'm talking about you ever
heard of this no can you Google that I
might have gotten the phrase wrong but
it wasn't a retrograde oh is it when
you're 27 yes yeah I know you're talking
about not when you're 27 but it's like
the point in your life
uh at which you start to like take on
responsibility for yourself and like
take care of yourself instead of
letting other people take care of you
I guess yeah there are certain trends
that everyone can
follow where like five years after
you're born for example I don't think
this is accurate like the planets are in
the same spot that they were when you
were born so it's supposed to bring
bring back certain things from before
and that's why like if you look at like
a random astrology Twitter account for
example
um they might say like oh things are
building from like what started two
years ago because that's when the
planets were like whatever whoa yeah
that's
that's [__] crazy this [__] is for
narcissists
not you but like people who who go deep
on this and they're like ironic coming
from a Leo yeah
to wake up and like read your in your
[__] computer your handheld computer
screen phone and be like oh my God all
these planets are like in different
places and what's gonna happen to me
today yeah yeah
from some [__] distant planet yeah
miles and miles away yeah ew it's like
at three o'clock yeah
oh it's gonna be horrible
yeah how are the planets how are the
planet's alignment going to affect me
uniquely yes I don't give a [__] about
anyone else yeah or how you know what
I'm saying yeah no offense
you don't actually I'm I'm you're
open-minded about you guys what I care
about it for you guys that's why I
learned yeah yeah yeah yeah you're not a
narcissist no you're not yeah yeah you
manifested this yeah
yeah and college over was like I must
learn this
inevitably work on the TMG show no it's
not too impressed you're like I need to
save them I need them to know their star
signs and what this could be for their
life so let's read our horoscopes then
yeah
can we can we just Google them I have an
account that I kind of like but they're
poems I think we should do that I'm sure
yeah they're really funny yeah sometimes
they're amazing can we just read the
non-po poetic ones first yeah let's go
back to it yeah go back to what you just
did Leo horoscope there it is Leo
horoscope
December 13
2022. can we get drama lighting please
oh excuse me uh this is from February 7
or whatever yeah [__]
uh you will find that you relate very
well to others today Leo and your
communication will prove to be quite
valuable you may find yourself in the
position of arbiter simply because you
have the detached mind that people need
to resolve disputes
take an active role in the lives of
those around you and see how your own
life benefits from the generosity of
your actions oh [__] narc [__] to the
fullest dude imagine reading this [__]
and going to your friends being like
I think I may be in a position to solve
your problems today yeah I pay my
[__] light bill
get your authentic self with guidance of
a psychic advisor click here for the
first three minutes of your reading for
free all right give me one do mine now
Sagittarius I'm just talking about Noel
what if that [__] was just like L Riz
dude
today you can expect to act awfully
retrograded you aren't ill yeah
the prevailing tone today is a mix of no
no dude call out the whole thing though
your sun sign the horoscope and the date
where even is just Sagittarius
Sagittarius okay sorry this is my daily
Sagittarius horoscope not mine well no
it is mine [__] it it's this is my
horoscope no one else says this is mine
December 13th February 7th 2022.
the prevailing tone today is a mix of
conflicting energies that might put some
stress on your heart
it's nothing you can't handle though
Sagittarius I love when they call me
that yeah
in fact if anyone can make the most out
of today you can damn straight
tap into your aggressive yo tap in okay
yeah yeah tap into your aggressiveness
and act boldly toward the object of your
desire
make sure there is harmony among those
around you and everyone's needs are
taken care of
wow get your authentic self with the
guidance of a psychic advisor click here
to get the first three minutes of your
reading for free
wow I mean
how do you feel
like amazing act boldly towards the
object of your desire I really want this
Bugatti
okay let's read the poem ones now okay
interesting that I just thought of is
there's this app that people use where
you can do it based on who you are as
like your whole chart which is supposed
to be better it's called I forgot what's
called doesn't matter people love it but
they're like tell me like oh add me on
this and the lady who made the app that
came out after the fact and said she
used to just put put push notifications
on to [__] with people like that weren't
true am I crazy she'll just write [__]
that's yeah wow just be like ah you're
gonna have a bad day today
yeah really yeah awesome it's great
that's [__] awesome also an astrology
app is ripe for AI yeah oh just
crunching all that data and just making
people feel special yeah imagine people
like the computer said I'm gonna have a
good day today yeah oh did it yeah
[Laughter]
astrology by Poets they post it on the
Sunday of every week
so it's kind of sorry I'm making you do
this look because then they start
retweeting all the stuff you have to go
through right yeah I know I saw oh Miley
Cyrus whoa a fellow Sage whoa sign those
pizza toppings
signs as pizza toppings oh oh so you're
weird Cody you're weed
um down straight
down straight I am this is your gel
pepper honey Leo is pepperoni sauce yeah
meat
is weed a pizza topping
it is now who who who does that who eats
weed pizza oh you ever been to Humboldt
County no I think it's just because
Sagittarius are built different yeah
maybe
that's [__] crazy just weed just weed
on Pizza like not even baked into like
not even you know
I guess it kind of works if you eat raw
weed you get high yeah
right yeah yeah you do how do you know
right week of 12 11 in Sagittarius
finding the source can be fun sometimes
right now you just want to be there
what you must know is that you can be
anytime
you can be anytime take a trip into a
place you've read about
yeah babe I think I'm going to Bali this
weekend yeah
week of 12 11 in Leo
it can all happen again oh [__]
even if you think it is over
it is far from the yellow and red Sun
that bleats at you
roses will be given
whoa this sounds like Game of Thrones
narration or something yeah
yeah
this is actually the opening line to the
Warhammer uh campaign
I had a hair auras of heresy
no that's a new one I think I got that
wrong so yeah
um
oh you're welcome to sit around for the
Warhammer talk or not it's up to you but
we appreciate the readings I mean this
was massively informative yeah it was it
was I liked it thank you no I did like
this it was actually a great idea yeah
everyone clapped for OVI and her genius
segment thank you guys
appreciate it everyone be nice to I mean
you can hang all right I'll say yeah
okay all right fine it has no difference
you'll be on the other side of the
console
you'll either be laughing about me yeah
yeah yeah exactly yeah
what's up with that horoscope [__] that
[__] was so corny dude